hey everybody welcome to the great big
story youtube channel i'm dave i'm
jillian let's get to the show
today's episode is all about getting
high like these people in spain who
climb each other to make the biggest
human tower it's crazy i can't wait to
show you guys let's go
a castel is a structure formed of human
people
it's a human tower
castells are a catalan tradition of over
200 years
today there are over 80 different
colliers or teams spread throughout
catalunya every two years we have a
competition the 12 best teams will
perform at the concourse in
tarragona i'm proud to be a member of
the casteles de bila franca the casteles
de billa franca have won the concourse
for seven consecutive times we hope to
make it eight consecutive victories
these are very big structures very big
castles and they require three or four
hundred people at a time to make these
kind of constructions
and they can reach heights of 15 meters
the most important thing of when we try
to make the castles is obviously the
safety of the people involved we have
very small children of the age of four
or five who will climb to the very top
of the castle everybody is working to
make sure that this is the safest
possible activity for them this is very
important because occasionally
castles will collapse
and it
looks spectacular but it can be very
dangerous it's quite common for people
to break a leg on arm shoulder injuries
as the castle progresses the pressure
builds everybody is trying to find a
little bit of oxygen in in the bottom of
the castle there have been times when
people are fainted or collapsed but you
still have to keep going because you
have the collective responsibility that
you don't want to let the team down
[Music]
you hear the final music that you know
the castle is completed you can relax a
little bit but you still have to
concentrate because this is the most
dangerous part of the castle because if
you relax too much the structure can
collapse very very quickly
why am i a castelli to be a fighter
this is a very complex question and i
don't really have an answer
you can't explain it it's impossible to
explain
you have to feel it if you feel it you
understand it
in our next story we're going to meet
the best female rock climber and she
happens to be a teenager
let's go climb with her
right after school i just like try to
like run to the gym so i can climb
[Music]
it's a dangerous sport but the only
thing that i'm afraid of is not being
able to get to the top
[Music]
with climbing i don't think that it
really matters with how big you are if
you're smaller you can hold on longer
and your hands might be smaller so it
can fit more fingers on hold
i started climbing in central park when
i was 6 years old now i don't think i
can like live without it
[Music]
when you're close to the top of the
climb you're trying to do your forearms
usually feel like they're going to
explode and they're going to like burst
open and you feel like you have to let
go but with climbing you just can't let
go
i think that climbing is
it's obviously a sport but it's also
like a dance you sort of have to be able
to like flow
up the wall and come up with your own
technique to get to the top
i think
people are shocked if i do something
that they can't do with something
because i'm still really young and i'm a
girl so like doing something that even
if a guy can't do is pretty special
[Music]
hey jillian you ever been stung by a bee
yes it sucks right it's the worst i hate
it this guy has been stung over a
thousand times for his work all in the
name of science
[Music]
this is justin schmidt yeah my name is
justin schmidt he's an entomologist and
i'm an entomologist i basically study
stinging insects
[Music]
he's been stung by a lot of insects i've
probably been stung at least a thousand
times he reviews insect stings the way a
sommelier reviews wine pure intense
brilliant pain like walking or flaming
charcoal with a three-inch nail embedded
in your heel which insect was that
that's the bullet ant
this is his lab in tucson
[Music]
this is his harvester ant
this is his vinegaroon
this is his tarantula hawk
these are some more harvester ants in a
park near his lab
he is the creator of the schmidt pain
scale this schmidt pain scale is
basically a scale to rate the
painfulness of stinging insects on a
scale of one to four a one would be a
sweat bee two would be something like a
yellow jacket wasp the three would be
something like a harvest strand and a
four would be a tarantula hawk
how bad is a four
four it's absolutely excruciatingly
debilitating incapacitating just shuts
you down just absolute sheer
pain there's just nothing you can really
do about that
i don't think i'd want to be stung by a
whole bunch of different fours i don't
think i could endure that for very long
let's be clear justin schmidt doesn't
just go out and get stung on purpose
it's just that he's dedicated his life
to studying well my passion is insects
and stinging insects in particular yeah
i get stung but that's that's all just
part of the passion you know that that
gives me data you know sting
helps me in understanding what the
insects doing i get to be out in the
sunshine and out in the rain out in the
environment studying these magnificent
beautiful insects
it's just just such a joy
i can't imagine anything i'd rather do
more
[Music]
now we're gonna head to peru and hang
out with two members from the swedish
ski team and they're doing it on sand
not snow
[Music]
[Music]
cerebenko is the biggest sand unit in
the world i had no idea people could ski
in a place like this
once you're at the top you have about
four thousand feet or vertical drop
until you get to the bottom i will
remember that moment for the rest of my
life
[Music]
my name is emma dalstrom i'm from sweden
and i'm a professional free skier
i'm especially i'm also a professional
free skier we're both on the swedish
national team
we travel all over the world to ski but
we usually go to the mountains where
it's cold and snowy
when we got to peru we started in a
small oasis called wakachina
you would look around and all you could
see is desert
[Music]
[Applause]
i was really nervous for my first round
in the sand because obviously it's not
snow
it felt sticky in the beginning but when
you got some speed it felt pretty
similar to snow actually
[Music]
it felt pretty cool to ski in shorts and
a shirt
[Music]
[Applause]
we stayed there for about three days and
did some rails and jumps and then we
headed out to cerro blanco which is
basically one big mountain of just sand
once we were at the base of cerro blanco
we hiked with all our gear for about
three or four hours
by the time we got to the top it was
completely dark
that next morning when we first saw the
view
that was magic
i watched the sun come out over the
mountains
and then we just dropped in
[Music]
it was such a crazy feeling and i was
smiling the whole way down
[Music]
thanks for getting high with us today
don't forget to click the horse to
subscribe and leave a comment below see
you next time
bye